The great resignation
is continuing to loom.
There are more than 11 million
unfilled jobs right now.
We hear from businesses
all over the country,
that it's very hard to hire people.
Almost two years into the pandemic,
workforce participation remains slumped,
while job openings are near record highs.
And, this is coming at a time
when the recruiting process
is going through a radical transformation.
Companies in the past
who were maybe getting
dozens of applicants
for a single vacancy.
Now, they're getting hundreds,
maybe even thousands of applications.
And, so, software has come
in to automate the process
of looking through all of
these different candidates.
If you've applied for a
job in the last five years,
you've probably been
impacted by this technology,
whether it was screening your resumes,
making you play games to
analyze your personality,
making you go through some
other automated system.
And, some people are fighting back.
Who's accountable when those
AI machines break the law?
Why it's important that
Congress take action
to ensure that big tech
is held accountable.
They claim there is labor
shortages, but there is
a plethora of people out there
who are looking for jobs .
We're at a moment of growing
crisis with AI hiring.
And, that's why people are eager to act.
Amidst this whirlwind of disruption,
one has to ask the question,
how did we go from this to this, to this?
More than a decade ago,
instead of just replying
to a job in a newspaper,
printing out hundreds of resumes,
and sending them out
physically to companies,
now you can apply to even
more companies all at once
by doing it over the internet.
If you hate going to work
and your coworkers don't respect you.
Hey, dummy.
It's probably time - you need a new job.
Companies now,
they're getting hundreds,
maybe even thousands of applications.
And, so, software has come
in to automate the process
of looking through all of
these different candidates,
effectively using something called ATS
or applicant tracking systems.
These systems effectively
track different applicants,
look through their resumes,
and take them even potentially
through the whole process.
They will take candidates
who are at the top,
the middle, and the bottom of performers
as deemed by a particular
company or hiring company,
and then train their systems
based on those judgments.
And, then, use that as a baseline
on which to make it's
own automated judgements
about whether someone is good or bad.
Not just students,
experienced professionals.
They just don't know that these tools
are used so frequently.
Gracy Sarkissian
runs New York University's career center,
where she gives tips to
optimize applications
for AI systems.
Students will encounter
AI tools in an interview,
if they're doing a virtual interview.
Some folks will also counter
AI powered assessments
as part of their interview process,
depending on the industries
in which they're entering.
Well, the use of the
software is very prevalent.
There was a recent Harvard
business study that came out
showing nearly every single one
of the Fortune 500 companies
use this kind of software.
Large companies are never gonna
be able to stop using this.
They just have no choice,
because of the inbound
flood of applicants they get
every single day.
Most vendors position their software
as something that can
alleviate the human bias,
which has shown to be endemic
to the hiring process.
But, critics question whether AI
is actually injecting fairness
or just making those same
biases more efficient.
I definitely think there is
a segment of the population
that is being excluded
or not fully represented.
And, they are being left to the wayside.
This is Jamaal Eggleston.
He's a work readiness
instructor at the Hope Program,
a nonprofit that helps
New Yorkers find jobs.
My students aren't prepared for it.
And, coming from a population
that might not be, again,
as familiar with the technology,
they run into pitfalls,
and they don't do as
well as other communities
when encountering these AI.
Since US companies don't have to disclose
when they're using AI,
many applicants are still writing resumes
catered to the human eye,
rather than to AI.
When people tell you
that you should dress
up your accomplishments
or should use non-standard
resume templates
to make your resume stand out,
when it's in a pile of resumes,
that's awful advice.
The only job your resume has
is to be comprehensible
to the software or robot
that is reading it,
because that software
or robot is gonna decide
whether or not a human
ever gets their eyes on it.
Ian Siegel runs ZipRecruiter,
one of the dozens of AI companies
which transformed the
job hunt in recent years.
You want to write your resume
for robots, not for humans.
These softwares not only review them
to decide who gets passed to a human,
but another thing they do is
they write simple summaries
of who you are for those humans,
so that those humans may, in fact,
never see your actual resume.
And, it's not just resume screening
that has changed.
Initial job interviews and assessments
are being automated at
companies like Goldman Sachs,
Delta Airlines, and Walmart.
This screen may look familiar.
You have a minute or
two to answer questions
or play an assessment game,
which will determine whether or not
you move on to the next round.
So, we decided to try
out one of these systems
for ourselves.
Talk about a time when I
was overwhelmed or stressed.
I had an employee who's working style
and my management style were not in sync.
Alright, playing the first game,
it's kind of like a
remembering, memorizing.
Four, six, seven.
And, you have to, okay,
so it's like pattern recognition.
Oh.
Okay, maybe I'm not getting the job.
I don't know how much this
is going to tell about a person.
What?
Okay, your assessment has been submitted.
Please, click the button
above to continue.
While our tests were unscored,
many companies algorithmically rank
interviews based on
word choice, vocal tone,
and facial expression.
A lot of people are missing out.
A lot of people are not giving back
what the interviewer is looking for,
because it was programmed a certain way.
These things are programmed
by a certain segment
of the population
that might not be totally inclusive
or not be fully aware of
how other cultures emote.
I believe race is a part of it.
I know it's trying to be...
Trying to leave race out of it.
I know it's trying to be not biased,
but some things are inherent,
even if it's unconscious.
I like to call it the
ghost in the machine.
In a statement,
HireVue said its systems
are rigorously audited
for adverse impact,
meet all regulations,
and only analyze word choice.
Last year,
the company announced it
discontinued facial analysis,
in part over bias concerns.
Applicants trying to navigate
this new world of hiring
find themselves looking
for help on social media.
This is how to beat automated
resume screening software.
Here's how to trick the
online job application.
If you know how to play the game,
you're actually able to stand out on top
as the best candidate.
One controversial strategy
is copying an entire job
description into your resume,
hidden with white font,
in order to trick the AI
into picking up keywords.
They won't be able to see that you have
all of those qualifications
and its exactly what they
have on their website,
because it's all white.
It's eventually going
to go to a human being,
that's going to look at that resume,
and say, this is ridiculous.
It's not about beating the system.
I think that that thinking
is not gonna help candidates
to be most successful.
What helps you be most
successful in the job search
is to know that the world
of work is always changing.
There are tech vendors
that help candidates optimize
their resume for systems.
We have a tool that we use at NYU,
other universities use it,
it's called VMock.
Students can put their
resume into the system
and it will give them a score.
And, one of the things
that it's scoring for
is how likely it will be
to be picked up by an ATS
for a particular industry.
While elite universities have access
to resume optimizing tech,
others may be left behind
in this new world of work.
There are millions of people
who are being left out of the job market,
because hiring software is
discounting them very early on
on the process,
when it scans their resumes.
We have students who...
Some had bouts with incarceration,
some of our students are college students,
some of our students are long-term workers
who have been laid off
because of the pandemic.
And, these are good people
who have great experiences,
who can add and become assets
to a lot of these companies.
For example,
a person who, perhaps,
spent some time in the military
or someone who went on parental leave
might have a year or two
long gap in their resume.
Now, if you were going to
interview with a human being,
you might be able to explain
why that gap is there,
but an algorithm doesn't
necessarily see that.
It just sees that,
between a couple of years,
you weren't working.
A lot of times, they get no response.
And, it's really hard,
because there are...
They don't know what they did wrong.
They don't know if they
did anything wrong.
There's this term,
the black box of artificial intelligence.
What's happening with
some of these algorithms
is they might be discounting
hundreds of different types of people,
but even the people who create
the software don't know why.
In a statement,
icims, one of the leading ATS vendors,
said it takes these concerns seriously,
and has a team focused on responsible AI,
and follows industry
initiatives on fairness.
Algorithmic discrimination
is difficult to prove,
but it's been revealed by audits.
Amazon scrapped its AI
recruitment tool in 2018,
after it discriminated
against applications
which listed women's colleges or sports.
In another system,
the best predictors of job performance
included being named Jared,
or having played high school lacrosse,
according to an auditing law firm.
The algorithms that are being used
to look at people's resumes,
to conduct interviews,
they've been trained on data
about previous applicants,
is over perhaps the past decade.
That's how machine learning works.
No one explicitly told these systems
to discriminate,
but they were trained on millions
of biased hiring decisions.
The fear with these algorithms
is that you take bias data in,
because they're using
the wisdom of the crowd
and the crowd is clearly biased,
and what you're really
doing is perfecting bias.
That's the accusation that's been made.
The reality is that when
we deploy these algorithms,
we, as the software
engineers and programmers,
get to make choices about
what data the algorithm
can and cannot use.
We can say to the algorithm,
you never get to see someone's name.
If I tell you someone's
name is Jeremy Levine.
You know something about them.
If I tell you somebody's name is Natasha,
you know something about them.
And, by removing them,
we create the most level
playing field we possibly can,
so as much as possible,
it's a merit-based system.
While automated hiring tools
have become ubiquitous,
public perception hasn't caught on.
Recent Pew surveys found that
most Americans didn't know resumes
are being screened by computers
and most considered the
practice unacceptable.
But, one crucial group is
paying attention to AI,
lawmakers.
The European union has
unveiled its proposed strategy
for artificial intelligence,
including regulations on
transparency and data protection.
Concerns bout how this technology
could exacerbate discrimination,
for the FTC, I think, foremost,
the FTC needs to be making sure
that we're fully
understanding this technology.
A federal civil rights agency
is scrutinizing automated hiring tools,
while Illinois and DC have explored
some of the nation's first
AI hiring regulations.
The Federal Trade Commission
recently gave a message
to companies using AI,
hold yourself accountable,
or be ready for the FTC to do it for you.
In New York,
we just enacted one of the
first AI hiring regulations
in the country.
Albert Fox Cahn
runs a technology advocacy group
and participated in New York's task force
to understand the impact of AI systems.
The bill basically started off by saying,
before you sell this technology,
you'll have to do an audit,
and you'll have to tell people
when this technology has been used.
And, when you look at what this bill did,
it was regulation in name only.
Having an audit can be useful,
but when that audit is done
by the software vendor themselves,
well, that's not worth
the paper it's written on,
and it's absurd.
But, in the New York law, you can't sue.
It doesn't matter how
egregious the software is.
It doesn't matter how biased.
You don't get your day in court.
And, without that, none
of these bills can work.
In response,
some of the world's largest companies
like IBM and Facebook parent Meta,
have devised an auditing
standard for AI and hiring.
However, critics say
that industry standards
can't replace true government regulation.
We don't trust companies to self-regulate
when it comes to pollution,
we don't trust them to self-regulate
when it comes to workplace comp,
why on earth would we trust
them to self-regulate AI?
Look, I think a lot of the
AI hiring tech on the market
is illegal.
I think a lot of it is biased.
I think a lot of it
violates existing laws.
The problem is you just can't prove it,
not with the existing laws
we have in the United States.
So, a big part of this is playing catch up
to open up discovery,
to open up the court process,
to say you can look at these
algorithms more easily.
With widespread adoption,
the use of AI hiring tools
is less the future of work
and more like the present.
Virtual assessments, interviews,
and job applications likely
aren't going anywhere,
but it's up to the employers
to decide how much of their process
they really want to automate.
Smaller companies have a
little bit more choice here,
because they don't get as many applicants
as the big companies do.
So, one thing that's been suggested to me
by people in the recruitment industry
is actually maybe the small
to medium-sized businesses
should just be a little bit more critical
in their thinking
of whether they really
want to use this software.
Because, in some cases,
just using a human being
to interview someone,
even to look through all the resumes
might stand a better chance
of finding that star,
that star employee that
they're looking for.
Keep a segment or a avenue
open for an older person,
for a person who was incarcerated,
for a person who's young,
for a person who's just not
aware of these technologies,
so they can also have an
opportunity to get hired.
We can't solely base
something as important
as finding a job,
as finding a career,
to only to AI.
It's hard to fight against something
that has been programmed
one way or the other.
We can only teach our students
how to navigate these waters.